as podcast has bad words hmm
hello everybody welcome to the minerals
podcast we discuss what it means to live
a meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today oh boy yeah today we're
gonna talk about some heavy topics
including trauma we're gonna talk about
bereavement traumatic stress we're gonna
talk about sorrow and maybe even
traumatic death and we're gonna do that
with today's guest dr. Joann cacciatore
is here joy thank you for being here
thank you for having me thank you for
talking about what no one wants to talk
about no it's it's an important subject
and we're just so glad that we can have
an expert on the show to kind of help us
talk through some of this stuff you know
it was it was Johann Hari who connected
us with you and he he's on our podcast
so I made a few months ago and he said
hey there is this research scientist at
Arizona State University you've got to
talk to because a lot of our audience
have suffered from some sort of trauma
or maybe they're going through some
trauma right now and so we have
questions from them but before we get in
to those questions I thought maybe we
could talk a little bit about you Joann
and sort of your journey here and maybe
start with something that happened to
you in in 1994 can we talk about that
yeah absolutely I was a stay at home mom
being a mom and I had three children and
was pregnant with my fourth and she died
and they didn't find an explanation for
her death
there was no identifiable cause after an
autopsy and it sent me into a downward
spiral in a pretty dark place where I
wasn't sure I wanted to be around
anymore I wasn't sure how you lived
through something like that and more
importantly the social support system
failed me and my family there wasn't any
kind of systemic support and so within a
few months I weighed 88 pounds as I
couldn't get food passed the lump in my
throat I had trouble sleeping I
experienced hypnagogic experiences
during sleep I thought I was losing my
mind it was pretty terrifying and pretty
lonely and
then a few years later I mean I just
kept going you know one second at a time
because that's all you can do in the
face of such trauma and grief
especially absent good social support
and so I just took it one minute at a
time and eventually the the minutes turn
to days in the days to weeks in the
weeks to months and eventually started a
non-profit group and you know continued
to do my own work with grief and still
do it's been it'll be 26 years since
she's been dead pretty soon so yeah
thank you for sharing that and you know
it's fascinating right before we turn
the mics on Ryan was mentioning a story
and this is not an uncommon story this
happens to us all the time where we'll
be out on the road we'll be out on tour
like a book tour or a podcast tour and
we might do a hug line afterward and
sometimes people come up and and tell us
their stories and they'll say you know
my husband just died or my son just died
and I'm experiencing this amount of
grief or sometimes they'll say you know
it's been over a decade and I still
experience this grief and so it's for me
I was I hate to say this but this is the
truth for a long time until I was about
thirty so almost a decade ago I was a
bit of a trauma skeptic in a way and I
know there are probably some people who
are listening to this and they're
thinking well unless you just came back
from war for you had an immediate family
member died there's then trauma doesn't
exist it only exists for those
particular people and while obviously we
recognize that it does trauma manifests
in a bunch of other ways as well it
doesn't require such a terrible car
crash sort of thing in order to
experience trauma right yeah I mean so
so the thing about trauma is that it
incites something called traumatic
stress and that's why we say that trauma
is such a bodily or somatic experience
so if you think about let's let's reduce
trauma to to intense intense traumatic
stress and then you have a continuum so
traumatic stress is all the way on this
end of the continuum distress might be a
little bit further this way and your
everyday stress is somewhere in the
middle and then over here you have
something called you stress EU stre SS
and that's a kind of sub
subjectively felt good stress right so
before just before the first kiss
you know the butterflies in the stomach
kind of thing right so if you think
about stress on the body you know so
much of what happens in here is
subjective right so some people cope
with the day-to-day stress of paying the
mortgage or you know getting the kids
ready for school or making meals and and
they cope with stress quite well and
some people are a little less stress
resilient most people experience you
stress as kind of exciting and they
experience it subjectively as a good
kind of stress but when you start to get
over on this end of the continuum you
get to distress or even further out
traumatic stress then then we're talking
about you know life altering even if
it's not permanent because of a death
you're talking about what are
potentially for people life-altering
experiences and quite often those will
main remain repressed for a long period
of time and the reason I say I was a bit
of a skeptic until I was about 30 is I
think I repressed a lot of my own
traumatic childhood Ryan and I both grew
up really poor but a lot of substance
abuse and physical abuse in the
household we've known each other since
we were fat little fifth graders and my
very first memory as a kid is of my
father extinguishing a cigarette on my
mother's chest and for the longest time
like I knew that was there as a memory
but like I didn't I never really
unpacked it I I sort of I ran from it
almost and Ryan has talked in the past
about when he was in junior high school
the SWAT team kicking down his door and
raiding the house and that's a traumatic
event to someone who's 10 or 12 years
old right but quite often we we don't
address those things so they they stay
they stay there for a while and it's
almost as though they they grow over
time is that accurate well I think they
asked to be seen and when we don't see
them they come and to be seen in other
ways right the writer Catherine Porter
said the past is never where we think we
left it mmm
and so I tell people all the time we
need to deal with those things or they
will deal with us and so I think you
know so for example some of the problems
with addictions that we see and I'm not
just talking about substances we can be
addicted to a lot of things consumerism
yes porn gambling drink drinking
obviously substances drugs
TV social media work exercise yoga
I mean spiritual practice there are all
thing kinds of things that we can use to
sideways take us out of our emotional
experiences that are if you keep
excavating and getting underneath the
layers that have their root 'let's
in our past trauma well let's dive into
some of these questions here our first
one is from Carly in Selma California I
am a 26 year old single mom of two I've
been single now for about a year coming
out of a 12-year abusive relationship
with an addict I'm a full-time student
online and just about to get my
associate and I have to file for
bankruptcy soon so that's just kind of
where I'm at socioeconomically but I'm
gonna journey into finding how to be
happy just with myself just being the
present and I want to show my girls love
and how to enjoy life and love love
themselves intrinsically not because of
what we have or what we do or what we
look like or anything just because of
who we are so dream we've got a lot to
unpack here 26 year old single mom of
two congratulations by the way Carly for
getting out of an abusive relationship
a 12 year abusive relationship in he was
an addict and obviously that manifests
and and different types of abuse whether
it's verbal abuse or emotional abuse
physical abuse
these are traumatic events right
bankruptcy can be a traumatic event and
now sort of starting over
can can be traumatic and in many ways
for a lot of you because people feel
lost and she's asking how do I yeah how
do I be happy which is I think the
question were ultimately all asking
right but also how do I show love to my
kids what what what would you say to
someone like Carly yeah I mean those are
all big questions right it's very hard
without sitting down and knowing Carly
because everyone is such an individual I
think I think we do a great disservice
in Western culture by focusing a lot on
happiness the more we seek happiness the
more elusive it is absolutely and so I
kind of rail against the happiness cult
of Western culture her I am for a life
of meaning yeah and say that the point
is not happiness the point is a
meaningful life and occasionally
happiness is a byproduct of that well
and in fact it often is because if
you're not so hyper focused on I have to
be happy have to be happy then you're
not constantly seeking it out here which
comes through you know whatever dresses
and makeup or shoes or you know partners
or drinking or whatever right you're not
constantly you're not what Gabor Ma Tei
calls The Hungry Ghost right and in his
book do you know GABA or Montes work
okay he's worth knowing all right so he
wrote a book called in the realm of
hungry ghosts he works with substance
abuse okay and and so that in Buddhism
The Hungry Ghost is the ghost that's
never fed you no matter what you eat
it's never satiated
nothing ever fills a ghost right and so
it's that it's it's what happiness
seeking does to us so what I would say
is one of the great existential you know
moments of our lives is when we realize
that happiness is not out here and it's
not in things and it's not even
something that you can summon from in
here it's something that is as Viktor
Frankl says a byproduct of a life
well-lived a byproduct of a life sir in
service to others and by others I don't
just mean humans I mean the earth and
the animals that we share the planet
with and others capital o in a unit of
oneness and so how she loves her
children I don't know anything about her
or her children but I can say that how I
love my children the most was by
recognizing that this moment is all we
have hmm literally I mean at any moment
I mean I could have a brain aneurysm
right now
and in five minutes be dead right here
in this room and if I stay with that
then the and I stay with the possibility
that my life could end any second yes
it's terrifying
all right that's mortality salience well
that's also grown-up cuz that's reality
yeah
and so when you live your life that way
you you really don't not in a trite and
superficial way do take you know take
every moment as a gift not in a trite
way like you really do take every moment
as a gift it really is a sacred offering
to have this moment and so when I'm with
my children who are now all grown but
when I'm with them you know I'm like
with them I'm like I loved like I love
you and they're like I know Mom you love
me and I'm like no but I really love you
you know I just have to you I have to
have you understand that and know that
right yeah and so it's for me
recognizing the finitude of our
existence is essential now that can
bring up death anxiety in people and so
sometimes people who have already you
know predisposed up predisposed
characteristics of anxiety are really
gonna have to work with that so I
suggest of course a teacher a good
teacher like a meditation teacher or a
Zen teacher I mean I had a teacher in
Zen and have a teacher in Zen and I am a
teacher to many and so because we need
somebody to help us work through some of
that a sounding board someone with
resonance especially if we're prone
toward anxiety right and fear yeah as
Josh said I mean yeah we we totally
agree with you know happiness's it's a
femme oh and I would argue that I was
you know chasing and getting happiness
during my 20s but as soon as I had a
hold on it it slipped out of my fingers
and it was just this constant moving
marker that I was chasing but you know
something else I think in Western
culture that we propagate a lot is you
know live your best life and I do think
that people should live their best life
possible but sometimes when you when you
have gone through a very traumatic event
and when you have a lot of stress and
you're in the tornado of you know of
craziness that sometimes we put
ourselves in maybe it's like you know
for for Carly its focusing on living
your best day like just start there and
then you can kind of build on top of
that so hopefully you can get to a point
where you are living your best life but
it's
now she talked about to which I think
will help her live her best life or live
her best days she talked about loving
herself and it's interesting I I didn't
I knew that saying but I didn't really
connect with that until you know maybe
five six seven years ago when I realized
what loving yourself is well actually
let me ask you how would you define like
loving yourself what what does that mean
to you well I I have a self compassion
practice so and the reason I love my
self compassion practices because I it's
come self compassion as different in in
so far as it's not contingent on outcome
and so I am really fallible and I screw
up a lot there's a lot of material there
and when I screw up I'm like oh well you
know I'll do better next time
I'll work harder next time I'll deal
with it you know I'll deal with it
become a better version of me and yeah
it's the begin again beginner's mind
Suzuki Roshi right so I think for me
self love is empty without self
compassion and that means being able to
accept that I that I make mistakes yes
and I don't I don't really want to be
perfect they're perfect people are
boring yeah we'd be a bunch of robots
when Ryan talks about living your best
life what we often conflate that with
living the perfect life and that life we
see that's mediated to us via our
televisions or Instagram or ever well
and that's one of the things I told you
about my care affirm right so that's one
of the things on the care from that that
being in nature teaches you is that
nature all things happen right and it's
it's just you know this the symphony of
a day and disaster little mini disasters
happen all along the way you know uh you
know a paid goes after a dog we have the
farm right okay goes after the dog and
and the goats get into the sheep streets
and you know shits just sorry shits just
happening literally everywhere right and
if you you know have a requirement of
perfection or everything being so
completely ordered and you don't have
that psychological flexibility you are
going to have a lot of suffering in your
life yeah I love that you know as I get
older in fact I was talking to
geordan about this earlier before before
the show I used to really just hate not
having answers and not knowing what
everything was all about and not
understanding why things happened and I
think it began with me understanding
like oh none of us make it out of here
alive there's not one person there's not
one person on this planet who is still
here that it's always been here and when
I when I finally realized that there's
actually some solace in accepting that
this might be the only life we have now
is there something beyond it who knows I
mean there's plenty of theories around
that right but what we do know is we
have right here and right now and when
when I was able to appreciate that like
a it helped me to really be grateful for
this I think Einstein said something
like if God doesn't exist you know how
lucky are we to have this one life that
we actually do have and I'm totally
doing a bad job of paraphrasing that but
it's true like when I look at the life
that I have now I really truly
appreciate having this experience as one
human experience the what that led me to
though is that now I actually can find
solace and not having all the answers
there's almost some kind of comfort or
maybe it's me getting comfortable with
not having the answers and I guess this
is my way to just tell Carly like it's
okay that you don't have all the answers
right now just figure it out on a
day-to-day basis figure out what living
a meaningful life is for you and some of
those answers will come but guess what
not all the answers are gonna come and
anyone's lifetime yeah a couple things
I'm gonna tell Carly first off one is I
would get really clear on what your
values are because if you want to live a
meaningful life you want to align your
actions with your values when we really
start to suffer where we feel that
discontent it is quite often because we
don't understand that what we're doing
is not in line with the person that we
would like to be right and that's why we
often turn to our distractions or
through our pacifiers is it's the easy
route but the easier route is not a
meaningful route it is it is easy it's
going with the flow but if you go with
the flow long enough you end up at the
Falls right yeah and Carly
to give you a hug as well so if you want
to come out to one of our tour stops
we're going on tour in April it's called
the les Coast tour I'm gonna give you a
couple tickets to that you're it's funny
the hug line makes me think of the care
form because what we're doing is is
we're trying to offer some support to
people but you talked about your care
farm how people come out with trauma and
they care for these animals and it's
it's really just fulfilling to like go
beyond yourself to help something else
and that can certainly help with trauma
- well let me give you a couple tickets
either come out to Sacramento or San
Francisco or LA I know you're sort of in
the middle of all three of those so
whatever's closed to you whichever one
you'd like to come to we've got a
special guest in every city we're doing
a live version of the minimalist podcast
so maybe pick your favorite guest out
all of those you can see all the guests
and all the dates over at the
minimalists calm slash tour but Carly
podcast Shawn will reach out to you and
give you a couple tickets to whatever
event you want to come to our next
question is from Lauren in Boston ever
since I lost my father and my boyfriend
left me in such a short time span I made
the decision to move from where I am now
to my home state to be closer to my
friends and family during this
transition I've been letting go with so
many things even habits and people that
don't add value to my life anymore I
want the new upcoming phase of my life
in my new state to be fresh and
untainted by my past however I have felt
at times that this mindset has caused me
to let go of too many things some things
that I feel wasteful getting rid of
because I know I will replace them
somehow I just don't want the original
items their quote unquote tainted by my
past for example I want to donate this
pair of jeans that I have attached
memories of my past to knowing I'll have
to replace them with new ones since it
is not the function or condition of the
item itself that doesn't bring me value
but the feeling it brings me that those
are bringing new value I want to add
that at this time I do have the
financial means to go out and replace
all things with new things but I'm
worried that doing this is not a
responsible financial decision to make
have you guys ever struggled with
wanting to get rid of items so you have
attached negative feelings and memories
to knowing you will just go out and buy
a
or slightly different version of it just
that you can start fresh how do I not
attach feelings to items if it were up
to me right now with the way I feel I
get rid of nearly everything I own and
buy all new things so this is
interesting joanne because before the
show we were talking about with your
daughter's things how you still have
some of those things that are very keep
you very close to her and you know have
a lot of meaning this is kind of a I
think like a reverse situation where the
things that she has is triggering all
this trauma that she experienced that
negatively she doesn't want to have
association with that so I guess you
know what do you get what do you got for
Lauren
well what I have for Lauren is that more
question I'm a researcher so I don't
have enough data actually I don't know
whether the feelings she's having are
related to the pain of losing her
partner mmm or the nostalgia and the
grief associated with her father's death
because those are very different
experiences yeah so if she had stopped
with father and there wasn't the other
part to this then I would say that that
anything that I don't like I'm not a fan
of the word trigger mhm so I use cue mm
I like that better - yeah well because
anything that gets us is just a knock
yeah it's just saying hello pay
attention mm-hmm right and so I don't
want to associate it with necessarily
something negative right if something
gets us if we're gut-punched by
something then it's time to take a step
back pause and reflect on what's
happening inside of us hmm so what I
would say is if she had stopped at her
father's the experience of losing her
father which can be a very painful
experience for most people I'd say well
let's talk about why those feelings are
cueing you and see if we can stay with
it
because the idea for me with grief
especially traumatic grief is I mean she
doesn't mention also how her father died
and her father's age and all of those
things can kind of matter so the thing
about traumatic grief is that I don't my
job as a counselor as a Reese
not to force people to bring their
trauma traumatic grief feelings
sensations emotions down because the
thing about traumatic grief is we
experience it and re-experience it
throughout our lives these are
catastrophic losses then that that to
which there is no end date okay so I
don't have a need to to ass wage this
the grief and the trauma on this side
what I do is help people build the
emotional muscle to carry it and so that
when it presents and represents itself
when you are queued you go okay I
remember this I got this I can do this I
can trust myself with it so it's
emotional resilience really it's almost
like it's it's hitting the gym for your
emotions and all and so when I when I
think about this these twin events that
happen because her two events happen to
me so that was started this whole
minimalism thing was my mom died my
marriage ended as she mentioned and the
voicemail within the same month and it's
actually hard for me although I can do
it it's hard for me to even uncouple
those two events because it was like
getting into a car crash and then that
car crash slams into another car and and
it's almost difficult to say well yeah
was I in two car crashes or was I in one
car crash it all sort of felt like the
same malaise in the moment and and it
sounds to me like what you're saying is
maybe she can uncouple those in a way
that is beneficial in fact it it's
really important to start to unravel you
know because what ends up happening it's
kind of like a balloon bouquet right the
strings when once they start to deflate
you have a bouquet and all of these
strings at the bottom and you don't know
what string belongs to what balloon
until you start taking them apart and
you go oh okay that's what this is about
and that's what this is about I mean you
know this is a this is really important
introspective work that we really need
to do this is part of our duty because
if we stay in our traumatic grief and
don't work with it then then we inhibit
our capacity to you to allow our pain
our own suffering and pain to manifest
as fierce compassion
world and what I mean by that is that
all pain is an energy grief is an energy
all emotions are energy the the word I
talk about this in my book the word
emotion comes from a Latin word Revere
which means to move through so emote and
you can feel it when you're angry you
can feel it moving through your body
when you're sad you can feel it moving
through your body when you're happy or
excited you can feel those moving
through your body those emotions right
if we can fully stay with it then when
they move then those emotions move
through us then we can stay with it in
the Nate and then they shift they start
to change right and then they can
transfigure they can transform into
something more powerful that's that's
the reason for my own fierce compassion
in the world is because I have been able
to fully inhabit all my trauma and all
my grief and not rush myself through it
because you can't rush yourself through
it doesn't work but then over time
slowly slowly slowly those emotions have
transformed into a place where they're
still they're still trauma and they're
still grief but I can I can transform
that into fierce compassion in the world
and that manifests through you know my
love of people and my service to people
but also animals and the earth my
mindful you know sort of inhabitation of
the planet this is amazing this is like
the best case for not suppressing these
emotions because well because I can
think of in the past when I've had
addictions where I was suppressing
emotions and just hearing what you said
has it's changed my perspective and I
wish my 25 year old self could have
heard that because when we have these
emotions yes we have to work through
them but not only that we have to kind
of let them you know flower in their own
way and see how we can use them you know
to our advantage if if possible like
like you've been able to do yeah and to
the advantage of everything yeah
absolutely right I mean that's
yeah and it's a force it's a it's a
movement it's movie R it's a movement
and I think that's why we have such a up
world is because everybody's just there
in grown up bodies but there are little
emotionally broken people trying not to
feel what they feel unless it's
happiness totally he was actually
actively covering up so not just like
not trying to feel but or he was trying
to not feel
right where you do it with opioids or
drinking or or whatever vice it is it
could be watching TV just to ignore
whatever feeling that you're that you're
feeling now let's let's get to Laurens a
few things she had here because I do
want to discourage her from Spartan ISM
right that's the other side of the sort
of OCD continuum
you know hoarding is one side Spartan
ism is the other and she says she's
letting go of bad habits and toxic
relationships I say that's great but you
don't want to let go of all habits you
don't want to let go of all
relationships because then you end up in
a very isolated place so she talked
about starting over and the good news is
we're always starting over we can always
begin again right but but also realizing
that we can carry forward the things
that continue to serve us whether it's a
relationship you want to say serve us I
mean part of that is us serving the
relationships as well also habits that
serve us well you don't want to just let
go haphazardly the key then is to let go
of that which is no longer serving you
or you're not able to serve anymore so
that you can move forward appropriately
would you have anything to add to that
perfect all right Laurel well I do want
to address the things that she talked
about how do you she's like how do I
stop holding on to memories when it
comes to things and I don't I don't have
a magic answer for that I think that I
think that things will always have the
ability to trigger memories now if she
has some things right now that are
triggering negative emotions and
negative memories and that's like the
pair of jeans she brought up I got to
get rid of those one thing I would
suggest to her is those things that are
triggering the bad memories that you'd
necessarily don't want to replace
because your genes are perfectly fine
and they still work like if you're
having that specific struggle I would
recommend maybe setting those things
aside so they're not constantly
triggering the memories and going and
finding someone like a professional who
can kind of help you work through these
emotions and then once you have let
those emotions surface and you've been
able to whether you know you use them
for a force of good in the world or
whether you just you figure out how to
work through those then you can maybe
get those things out of the closet and
then maybe
if you can deal with those feelings but
I totally agree Josh like we don't want
her to just we don't want to encourage
her yeah just throw everything that
makes you feel bad because that could
lead to totally different set of
problems yeah by the way if you get rid
of all of these triggers for your
memories you're still going to have the
memory right I mean and the reality is
and the research is very very clear
about this experiential avoidance
actually prolongs and exacerbates
traumatic stress yeah I mean that's what
substance abuse is all about it's about
avoiding everything we feel all the
triggers it's about numbing out and so
when we're reticent to say okay I'm
gonna make space for this feeling for
this object for this object that comes
with a feeling what we resist persists
yeah yeah well I'm gonna send you a copy
of our book everything that remains it
is the five-year journey of ryan and i
letting go of the things that were sort
of in the way but certainly not letting
go of everything making room for that
which is truly important reprioritizing
our values so if you like our podcast
you'll like the audiobook version of
everything that remains or if you want
the book book or the e-book we're happy
to send those to you as well oh and also
Ryan we were talking earlier about
getting clear on your values with
Carly's question there's a free
worksheet on our website if you want to
get clear on your values in fact a whole
essay they're called how to understand
your values it's at the minimalists comm
slash of e you can check that out as
well Ryan what time is it it is time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to nine three
seven two zero two four six five four
yes indeed those texts literally go
straight to both of our phones which I
love and hate I got the best question
the other day oh oh it was just someone
dealing with what hair product yeah yeah
I love answering that question nothing
no I got a question from someone who
which is going through like a bit of a
spiritual journey um you know they were
raised with certain beliefs now they
don't have their beliefs and that's
exactly where I'm at in life where it's
I was raised very strict Jehovah's
Witness and I had
you too oh wow we should talk about this
later get out of here my dad's an elder
right now he won't even talk to me we
got it we should have lunch after this
and talk about it yeah so but it's
interesting because wasn't it
when so you were into it then you were
not into it okay so I was into it and
you know how good it felt to have all
the answers it felt so good to be able
to no exert and it that's on them that's
not on me but like when I went from
understanding the like I really don't
have it figured out it was it was very
jarring and it's very difficult to you
know figure out where to place my
beliefs now so all that to say is it was
a great conversation that was having
with this person because I'm going
through the same exact thing and really
my answer to that right now if anyone is
wondering how I answered it I am well I
talked about earlier I'm getting
comfortable with not having the answers
and that is what really makes me feel
feel good about the journey I'm on I
don't I I hope I get answers you know
but if I don't have them I'm okay with
just having right now this moment and
that's what I try to focus on
I think Helmand was what said at one
point in one of his books the the
emotional maturity of a person can be
gauged by their ability to tolerate
ambiguity that's extra questions 9:37
two oh two four six five four we can't
answer every question we do our best
answer as many of them as we can
including some on the air during the
lightning round this is where Ryan and I
do our best answer of your question was
just a short shareable less than 140
characters response but not really
we just ramble and maunder all in a bit
until we get something that's pithy then
Shawn puts in the show notes that you
can copy and share on social media if
you like looks like we got a question
from Cavs is removing mementos of the
loved one you lost helpful for moving
past your trauma and grief so I've just
a pithy answer for this and maybe join
can help us unpack I think we talked
about a little bit already we don't let
go of the memories when we let go of the
stuff however I will say that sometimes
if you have a big hurdle it might it
does make sense to maybe get rid of the
trigger for a temporary period of time
it's not going to help you get rid of
the memory but may
maybe you can better address the memory
if it's not constantly clobbering you
I'll give you an example this morning I
was driving here I usually walk into the
studio but I was driving today because
of time and I saw someone on a bike get
hit by a truck
as I was driving in and it was actually
the bikes fault he was turning left at a
red light and the truck just came
through it hit him and I shouted no it
was involuntary down I was I was
traumatized by that in the moments
clearly not as much as the biker he
appeared to be okay like it could have
been so so so much worse but I can only
imagine like you wouldn't want to give
him a video of that and have him play it
on repeat all day either well I did film
it yeah so here's here's the dilemma
okay you've heard of habituation biology
101 right yes okay the problem is when
we avoid our trauma habituation never
occurs hmm and so we are we remain
reactive to the stimulus and so that's
the work that I do with people so when
they for example have seen their child
die
some people were there and saw a car
accident or pulled their child out of a
swimming pool when they've seen those
kinds of things the natural the natural
thought is to self protect and for a
while that can be a good idea until
until it's not a good idea because it's
still there I mean trauma is cellular I
mean you can feel it in your body for an
unlimited amount of time and so and it
will stay there and it will make us sick
if we don't deal with it and so
habituation can occur safely when you
have a really really well-trained and I
have to add that caveat because I have
met I'm a professor and I teach students
grad students how to be good therapists
and we definitely have a dearth of good
therapists effective therapists
especially ones who have done that done
their own shadow work because who you
are and your own
work or lack of work shows up in the
therapy office and so I teach students
how to do their own work so that when
they work with a client who has trauma
they can create a safe environment
because we have to feel safe in order to
approach the scene where we pulled our
child out of the swimming pool otherwise
we can't approach it because it's too
terrifying it's too paralyzing we keep
going into flight fight freeze and the
reality is you'll do that your whole
life if habituation never happens we
have to file some of the sharp edges off
and so so so the key is not to try to do
it when we're by ourselves if we don't
have the self skill or if we don't have
a lot of tools especially if you've had
a history city of trauma you you really
have to get with someone who's quite
well skilled in quite well-trained and
quite compassionate who brings a lot of
compassion and nurturance and resonance
to the relationship so that you can feel
safe enough to go deeply into your own
trauma and re-experience it in a safe
way so that your brain can start to file
some of the sharp edges off of that that
is that's that's amazing because it's
yeah what I'm hearing you say is that
you do want to be able to not relive the
trauma but you want it to be able to
come up and you want to be able to
handle it in a way that yeah that that
isn't going to put you right back in
that so you handle in a healthy way yeah
I mean okay so it's been almost 26 years
since my child died so there are
traumatic snippets that's I started
because your grief brain is a real thing
and so is trauma brain and so you know
like I slowly started to put together oh
I remember that I remember that and so
for a while I was like oh I don't want
to think about that I want to do
something else I want to do something
else
substance isn't were never my thing you
know like well I would go walking which
sounds like a healthy coping mechanism
if I wasn't walking to avoid feeling if
I was walking alongside my feelings it
would have been different and so avoid
avoid avoid not working for me not
working for me because every time it
came up it still had the same power over
me is it is a bad technique especially
long term it can be it can be you it has
some utility until we get somewhere safe
but we can't
pretend it didn't happen okay well I do
want to talk to you more about safety a
moment Brian I know you've got a pithy
answer for it yeah you know my answer is
this is letting go create space for
what's truly important so the question I
would be asking if I was Cavs is you
know if you let go of those those
mementos what are you making room for if
you just letting go to forget the past
it's probably not the best intention if
you're letting it go because you've got
a storage locker that you're paying $500
a month for filled of mementos and it's
causing you six thousand dollars a year
to hang on those and you're feeling the
monetary pain well that's a little bit
different than you are making room for
other things so the question isn't you
know does getting rid of mementos help
you move past your trauma and grief it's
really those mementos that you want to
let go of what are you making a room for
alright well before we get into our
added value segment and our listener
tips today it looks like we had a bunch
more surprise questions this week how do
you forgive and forget the experience of
betrayal from marital infidelity that's
a deep one Ryan we've got a lot to say
about that and I'm sure Joanne does as
well how do you break the cycle of
narcissistic behavior from someone who
is close to you how do you keep up with
good habits when you are depressed how
do you come to grips with parting with
your late husband's things one of the
benefits of forgiveness how do we move
on from guilt and we've got a bunch more
questions for Joanne if you want to hear
all that listen to this week's maximal
episode that's right you're currently
listening to our minimal episode but
each week Ryan and I and our guest
record an entirely different much longer
much more personal maximal episode on
the minimalists private podcast which is
the best way for us to fund this podcast
and keep it a hundred percent
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll receive a personal link
so that our maximal episodes play in
your favorite podcast app find all the
details at the minimalists comm slash
support Ryan what else you got for us
this week here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners hi
Josh and Ryan this is Jamie Lee
Salt Lake City Utah I'm calling in
regards to your last episode about a
cheerier decorating I think it was
episode 222 Alli from Springville had
posed a question about what to do to
stage her home and I had a couple of
suggestions there's a local thrift store
called di or desert industries they
actually have quite a few really
cool-looking decorative items so that
might be a place where she could go and
purchase stuff or not very expensive and
then donate it back when she's done but
she could also ask friends or neighbors
I don't know how your friends and
neighbors are but I have several friends
and neighbors who are really interested
in decorating and have extra decorative
stuff on hand and so that might be an
option if she just needs a few things
that she doesn't want to keep hey guys I
am Johnny K and I'm calling from
Sheboygan Wisconsin I just wanted to
leave a quick reminder for parents I am
a mom of a one-year-old and it's often
easy to get just caught up in all of the
toys and things that advertisement tell
us that we need the newest and coolest
gadgets and I just want to remind
parents out there that something that
your child needs but cannot be bought in
a store is love so instead of buying the
new toys have your child experiment with
maybe something they already have my
son's favorite toy is an empty box and
we color on it he plays on it and we
just have an amazing time with that
simple toy that's not even a real toy so
I just wanted to remind parents that
your child doesn't your love your
attention and just for you to be there
and that's not something that you can
buy alright y'all thanks again to Joanne
cacciatore for joining us today
check out her book bearing The
Unbearable we'll put a link to that in
the show notes we think you'll find a
lot of value in that it'll be helpful
for a lot of people real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
over on our resources page we have a
free ebook it's called the minimis rule
book because Ryan and I
figured out all the answers to life and
we're willing to share with you in a
free ebook it's the minimalist STATCOM
/resources it's called sixteen rules for
living with less but we actually think
there is no minimalist rulebook that's
why we made the minimal our rules and
even the nuances of those rules differ
between Josh and I but it's a great
starting point for someone who's looking
to help looking for some help setting up
some boundaries boundary is exactly the
right word it's sort of like putting a
fence around your house but you can also
move that fence because you realize
you've got more property then you might
suspect so you can move it in move it
out you can adjust these rules for taste
to mix my metaphors here but check that
out over at the minimalists comm
/resources it is a free ebook I think
it's maybe 30 pages so you can read it
really quickly and ones one sitting but
it's also beautifully designed by our
friends over at spire by the way you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
earlier ryan we talked about texting us
937 202 for six five four we're gonna be
doing some unscripted meetups just for
our private text group there we also
send you the Monday morning minimal
Maxim's each week and we respond to as
many folks as we can as well so if you
want to get on our text list there you
can text us personally we respond to a
lot of people just text that number that
I just gave you if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voice memo send it
over to podcast at the minimalists comm
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalists and if you want
our show notes in your inbox sign up for
our e-mail list over at the minimalists
comm and you'll receive our simple
sunday emails for free each week for
added value this week Ryan I sent you a
link to an album yesterday if you got a
chance to listen to it got through like
half of it but it's really good man I
the way I described it the guy's name is
clever and I described if Kurt Cobain
made a rap album it would be this out
but it's not really it's not Rock it's
not rap it's not pop it's not R&B it's
none of these things it's all of these
things and other things as well this
guy's name is clever and we've been
talking about trauma today and we dive
really deep in the trauma also in
the maximal episode on patreon but this
song is called commissary and it's yeah
I think there is this this trauma
culture within youth where they're
trying to deal with trauma the best way
they know how and quite often that
manifests in music whether it was Kurt
Cobain or it is today's young artists
who are looking for ways to deal with
the environments and the events that are
occurring to them so this is commissary
from clevers album who is clever and if
you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening yeah
we'll see you next time
and minimus